foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
feathers
in a beautiful
beautiful I wish I was special
[Music]
holy idiots dance
I want a perfect body
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
I told you a million times you keep your
grimy raccoon hands off by soon
I told you a million times I'm not a
damn raccoon
[Music]
again
a shield
[Music]
whatever makes you happy
you're so very special
[Music]
foreign
I want to see if these new gravity boots
worked on a slope
[Music]
here we go
sorry
you
think you could do better
bye-bye
[Music]
cheating that's a stupid little Pebble I
could do that with my dang finger
you're a bad dog
do not say that to me you are you're a
bad dog take that back come on that's
not cool nebula did you hear he called
me a bad dog and he refused to take it
back I don't care Cosmo is Peter okay I
don't know what are you going to do me
he's your brother it doesn't matter he
still doesn't listen to me yeah he has
been pretty mopey ever since Gamora died
she's not dead
she just doesn't remember anything from
the past few years nobody tells me
nothing mantis why don't you just touch
him you know make him happy I am Groot
gross no not like that touch him with
her powers and he's wrong to manipulate
the feelings of friends well at that
time you made me fall in love with my
sock well that was funny I guess it's
back to one of us touching him the other
way maybe we should draw straws no one
ever meant that Drex
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
what the hell